- We are thrilled and
honored to be here tonight
to pay tribute to the great Mel Brooks,
a comedic genius, and a legend-
(audience applauds)
Beyond compare.
- He was, of course, a
big part of our lives,
long before we were ever a part of his.
- Starting at age 11,
I replayed the "2000 Year Old Man" daily.
In fact, until I was about 14,
I slept with that record playing,
hoping to get subliminally funnier.
- Ah, what happened at 14?
- I discovered pornography.
- Of course.
(audience laughs)
- So when the opportunity arose
to actually work with Mel,
bringing the musical version
of "The Producers" to Broadway,
it was the realization
of a childhood dream.
- Same for me, even
while it was happening,
we knew it was such an
extraordinary and unique experience,
it could never be topped.
So thank you, Mel, for that
once in a lifetime opportunity
to become Bialystock and Bloom,
a memory we will always cherish.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- In all of his work,
Mel has always let humor lead the way.
He proved that if it was smart and funny,
you can joke about anything.
- Which is why he's won
every award known to man,
with the possible exception
of the Latin Grammy.
(audience laughs)
Although, I hear he's working
on an album with Bad Bunny.
(audience laughs)
- Now, Mel is the first to
make jokes about his age,
but we are not going to do that tonight.
- No, no, we're not gonna do that.
Although.
(audience laughs)
I will just say that
it is quite remarkable
that Mel is actually older
than this organization,
the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences.
- Well, that's actually,
Nathan, that's nothing.
Mel is older than penicillin.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
Yeah, he's older than the aerosol can.
- I had no idea.
- Yeah.
Older than FM radio.
- I think that's enough.
- He's older than polyester.
- Poly, he's older than polyester?
- Yes, yes.
- Really?
Wow, that is old.
(audience laughs)
Anyway, throughout
Mel's incredible career-
- He's older, older than the minimum wage.
- Well, now you're just making things up.
- Nuh-uh, nuh-uh.
(audience laughs)
- Anyway, throughout
Mel's incredible career,
he has occasionally had his detractors,
who have accused him of vulgarity,
to which he famously
replied, "That's bullshit."
(audience laughs)
- Mel, you're an institution,
and we are so proud to be here tonight
to see you officially institutionalized.
(audience laughs)
- And now, because it
just doesn't seem right
to honor Mel Brooks
without breaking into song.
(gentle piano music)
As the music suggests,
we're going to break into song.
Ladies and gentlemen, Tony
and Grammy Award winner,
and seven time Oscar nominee,
come on, give him one, Mark Shaiman.
(audience cheers)
(dramatic piano music)
As you all know, Mel is a famous EGOT,
and after tonight, he will
be the even rarer EGOOT.
(audience laughs)
He's a writer, performer,
producer, director, songwriter.
He catered tonight's affair,
and he knitted his own tuxedo.
(audience laughs)
Ladies and gentlemen, you name it, and?
♪ He can do it ♪
♪ He can make the whole world laugh ♪
♪ He'll take Nazis ♪
♪ And make you plotzes ♪
♪ Gonna double you in half ♪
♪ Every gag that's made you giggle ♪
♪ Probably started out with Mel ♪
♪ From Sid Caesar scenes ♪
♪ To campfire beans ♪
♪ If you don't die from laughing ♪
♪ You might die from the smell ♪
♪ He can do it ♪
♪ Every minute brings a joke ♪
♪ You can't top him ♪
♪ You can't stop him ♪
♪ He's awake, but he ain't woke ♪
♪ Being lauded and applauded ♪
♪ That is where this man belongs ♪
♪ So to hell, Mel ♪
♪ We'll regale Mel ♪
♪ 'Cause we love to sing his songs ♪
♪ He rode a blazing saddle ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ He wore a shining star ♪
♪ His job to offer battle ♪
♪ To bad men near and far ♪
♪ So throw out your hands,
stick out your tush ♪
♪ Hands on your hips, give 'em a push ♪
♪ You'll be surprised you're
doing the French mistake ♪
- Wait!
♪ I'm tired ♪
♪ Sick and tired of love ♪
♪ I've had my fill of love ♪
♪ From below and above ♪
♪ I've been with thousands
of men, again and again ♪
♪ They promised the moon ♪
♪ They're always coming and going ♪
♪ And going and coming,
and always too soon ♪
Right, girls?
(audience laughs)
♪ High anxiety ♪
♪ It's always the same ♪
♪ Ooh-xiety ♪
♪ It's you that I blame ♪
♪ It's very clear to me ♪
♪ I've got to give in ♪
♪ High anxiety ♪
♪ You win ♪
♪ I used to be the king ♪
♪ The king of old Broadway ♪
- It's good to be the king.
♪ The best of everything ♪
♪ Was mine to have each day ♪
♪ I always had the biggest hits ♪
♪ The biggest bathrooms at the Ritz ♪
♪ My showgirls had the biggest tits ♪
♪ I never was the pits in any way ♪
♪ We believe you ♪
♪ Thousands wouldn't ♪
♪ We believe you, every word ♪
♪ There'll be gala opening nights again ♪
♪ You'll see my name in lights again ♪
♪ I'll go from dark to brights again ♪
♪ My spirits high as kites again ♪
♪ I'll never suffer slights again ♪
♪ I'll taste those sweet delights again ♪
♪ No plethora of plights again ♪
♪ No blossoming of blights again ♪
♪ No frantic fits or frights again ♪
♪ Fame is in my sights again ♪
♪ I'll take those fancy flights again ♪
♪ I'm gonna scale the heights again ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ Bialystock will never drop ♪
♪ Bialystock will never stop ♪
♪ Bialystock will be on top again ♪
♪ I'll be on top again, hey ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ I wanna be a producer ♪
♪ With a hit show on Broadway ♪
♪ Lunch at Sardi's every day ♪
♪ I wanna be a producer ♪
♪ Sport a top hat and a cane ♪
♪ I'm gonna put on shows
that will enthrall 'em ♪
♪ Read my name in Rachel's column ♪
♪ I wanna be a producer ♪
♪ And now ♪
♪ And now it's ♪
- Everybody!
♪ Springtime for Hitler and Germany ♪
♪ Deutschland is happy and gay ♪
- But straight.
(audience laughs)
♪ No one ever made me feel
like someone, 'til him ♪
♪ Life was really nothing
but a glum one, 'til him ♪
♪ My existence bordered on the tragic ♪
♪ Always timid, never took a chance ♪
♪ Then I felt his magic and
my heart began to dance ♪
♪ I was always frightened,
fraught with worry, 'til him ♪
♪ Ah ♪
- No, no, don't.
- Don't help us.
- Please don't help us.
(audience laughs)
♪ I was going nowhere
in a hurry, 'til him ♪
♪ He filled up my empty life ♪
♪ Filled it to the brim ♪
♪ There could never, ever be ♪
♪ Another one ♪
♪ Like him ♪
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
(dramatic music)